[Musica]
pensate al sogno di una casa nuova
per chi lo vede un progetto lontano
provi a pensare ai colori che
sceglierebbe alla luce delle stanze
agli oggetti che porterebbe con sé dal
passato al futuro
perché una casa nuova invece già la
abita
provi a ricordare la fatica per
realizzarla le indecisioni nelle scelte
lo stress
ma anche tanto futuro
bene per me
una casa nuova è stata un vero proprio
sogno
ma da un altro punto di vista
quel mattino ero passato in ospedale per
un controllo
non dormivo da settimane
avevo un dolore che premeva sul polmone
e faticavo respirare non sapevo cosa
fosse
i medici non ebbero il coraggio di dirmi
che forse il tumore era tornato
così mi lasciarono andare a casa
ma io non volevo andare a riposare
e andai a quell'appuntamento immobiliare
che avevo fissato
entrai un ufficio pieno di
mobili antichi
fascicoli cartoni poca luce e immaginai
la
casa che avrebbe potuto diventare
cambiando i colori spostando alcuni
mobili per allargare la stanza
e cominciare a sognare
non so
se avrei scelto quella casa in
condizioni diverse
ma era l'attività più concreta nella
quale potesse investire
la mia mente
dal giorno dopo ero in ospedale
nessuno parlava di se sarei tornata a
casa nemmeno io
conoscevo il mio tumore da 14 anni è un
tumore raro è un tumore che attacca il
mio sistema nervoso e lento reagisce
bene alla chirurgia
molto meno bene alla radio e alla
chemioterapia
e rosato operata tante volte al gluteo
polmone sinistro polmone destro
sempre operata
questa volta era alla pleura
la pleura sono due strati sottili di
membrana con in mezzo un sottile filo
d'acqua
solo che io questa volta di acqua ne
avevo più di 4 litri per questo
comprimevano il polmone
il cuore e il diaframma
proprio io che mai volevo che nessuno mi
nascondesse niente sul mio tumore
io che nei momenti più delicati
ero andata dai medici da sola per paura
che i miei familiari mi nascondessero
qualcosa
la sentenza
era drammatica non ero operabile
sapevo tutto ma questa verità
non mi permetteva di fare nulla
così decisi di cambiare punto di vista
rientrare in quella casa era l'ultimo
barlume di vita
prima della notizia
così che ha mai l'immobiliarista mi feci
portare una piantina e cominciamo a
cancellare
i muri allargare le stanze aprire le
finestre togliere le tende nella mia
testa di notte quando non dormivo cioè
quasi sempre
e cominciava a metterci colori
quante emozioni nuove
perché la casa era altro rispetto alla
mia storia ma non era sufficiente dovevo
cambiare di nuovo punto di vista
i miei familiari
ce la mettevano tutta giocavo a carte
con mio padre nel silenzio
ma le loro facce erano la mia storia
era la nostra storia familiare
per fortuna
c'erano i miei nuovi compagni
di quella stanza i medici e gli
infermieri
ogni giorno venivano da me e insieme
costruivamo la strategia
per andare al giorno dopo
avevo cinque cicli di chemio davanti il
massimo che un essere umano può fare per
non rimanere avvelenato nel mio caso
specifico ma non pensavamo ai 5 giorno
per giorno
ricordo un giorno il più doloroso della
mia vita in ospedale
avevo fatto la seconda chemioterapia
e il mio corpo aveva reagito malissimo
non riuscivo a ragionare vaneggiava
ricordo che tentavo di giocare a carte
ma non capivo come si facesse
arrivo al medico in fondo alpi in fondo
ai piedi del letto io ero steso
familiari intorno mi guardò e mi disse
domani
starai meglio
stavo meglio il giorno dopo ma in quel
momento non gli credette
però lo guardai di feci un sorriso per
quanto potessi e una pernacchia la mia
ironia era una richiesta d'aiuto ti
sorrido rispondimi e lui mi fece una
grande risata
ricordo un infermiere la notte quando
non dormivo
uno in particolare giovane bello
delicato gentile gli chiesi perché fai
un lavoro così doloroso
e lui mi raccontò che lo aveva perso la
sua mamma così e curando noi kurabo un
po ancora anche lei
non era sufficiente dovevo ancora
cambiare punto di vista loro erano
dentro alla stanza avevo bisogno di
altre persone e altre vite così ebbe
un'intuizione
in vita i miei familiari ad andare a
vivere le loro vite
con altri lavori altre persone e poi
venivano raccontarmele però
avevo pensato di cambiare persone con me
nelle notti nel giorno persone che mi
potessero portare tanta loro energia e
così presi il telefono cominciai a
chiamare tutti gli amici
amici nipoti
giovani fresche idee
e risposero di giorno e addirittura con
i turni di notte
tenevo gelosamente questo foglio cui
turni perché volevo controllare io la
persona che sarebbe venuta a è
cominciato a sentire la sua energia da
prima
ea svilupparne il desiderio
per non pensare al resto
qualcuno veniva con una chitarra
qualcuno con la sua voce a cantare
gospel sapendo quanto mi piace il canto
e che significato di speranza per me
qualcun altro mi raccontava ai problemi
con i figli e io cercavo di
immedesimarmi e di dare un consiglio
si erano messi nei miei panni
erano momenti di grande gioia amore
bellezza al punto che a volte ancora in
casa ora che sono tornata dico che un po
mi manca
quella stanza
però io avevo un obiettivo particolare
dovevo salvarmi e quindi non era
sufficiente dovevo di nuovo cambiare
punto di vista
io che conoscevo il mio tumore in
squadra con i medici noi dovevamo
passare dalle cose che sapevamo e
conoscevamo di quel tumore a quello che
ancora non si conosceva ma da qualche
parte ci sarebbe stato speriamo
e così iniziai a leggere a studiare di
notte su internet cure innovative
e mi presentavo dai medici dicevo
proviamo l'immunoterapia
limone terapia consiste nell'amare
nostro sistema immunitario per
combattere il tumore come se fosse un
virus ma loro mi dicevano che non
funzionava e allora ancora a cercare
genomica
un sistema per analizzare i geni del
tumore non quelli con cui nasciamo tutti
quelli dentro al tumore
trovare un gene mutato che con quella
mutazione crea una proteina difettosa
miei geni però erano stati esaminati
otto anni fa ero in un protocollo di
ricerca con un nulla di fatto cinque
anni fa
tre mesi prima perché ero stato in
realtà operato anche tre mesi prima
e li avevano anche esaminato in quel
momento proprio in ospedale ma io
insistevo se questa è solo la strada che
troviamo proviamo di nuovo magari più
geni più opportunità e così abbiamo
fatto altri tre tentativi proprio
all'ultimo è arrivata a quella anomalia
genetica che in questo caso in una
benedizione no una cosa sbagliata allo
scoperto perfetto una su 320 e aveva due
medicine associate le cosiddette
medicine jolly che vanno bene su tutto
su organi diversi sui tumori diversi
l'importante è che qualunque sia il
tumore abbia quell'errore
e così io da quasi due mesi da quasi due
anni e scusate sono curata con questa
medicina il tumore si è ridotto non sono
più 4 gr 4 chili ma si è seccato e la
pleura
tanta gioia tante lacrime di gioia
amici parenti e medici
però
c'è un però
pochi mesi fa a luglio il tumore è
tornato
operabile
ma anche se non l'ho condiviso tanto
dentro di me quanta paura
quanta frustrazione
quanto dolore
quanta rabbia
dovevo cambiare di nuovo punto di vista
prendere tutte queste energie
negative ma gigantesche
convogliarle della benzina di un motore
che mi facesse a ripartire
ma ripartire per andare dove ancora
operata
non
nessuno mi poteva né tuttora mi può
convincere
che questa sarà l'ultima volta che non
capiterà più
sono domande che non hanno senso io
dovevo
ripartire col cuore e il cervello e
allora pensai una battaglia che avevo
lasciato in sospeso la battaglia della
disintossicazione
della dipendenza non se ne parla mai di
questa cosa ma i malati oncologici
assumono così tante droghe
io prendevo più di un grammo di morfina
al giorno
che dipendono da queste medicine avevo
tentato di fare quello che il protocollo
medico dice allungare il tempo di
distanza tra una dose l'altra ma non ero
mai riuscito a disintossicarmi del tutto
così quel motore con quella energia ci
ha provato
bene sono tre mesi che sono senza
oppioide
90 giorni in cui mi sveglio al mattino
appena mi sveglio
sento il fastidio mi bruciano le labbra
sento il tremore
sento un desiderio incredibile di
apprendere medicine poi mi alzo e se non
svengo perché la pressione bassissima
prendo il pensiero e provo ad attivare
la mia casa
le mie risorse
e cerco di usarle
per qualcosa
di vivo
ho capito che
certe domande non hanno senso non hanno
più senso
quando qualcuno mi dice come stai
io lo so che vorrebbero sentirsi dire
bene non faccio in tempo a rispondere
che qualcuno mi dice sei così bella sei
così
positiva è ovvio che stai bene
in realtà non sto così bene
però non mi interessa come non mi
interessano in generale le domande o che
non hanno risposta o che non
costruiscono futuro le domande che mi
interessano sono altre
che incontrerò oggi che non avevo
programmato
quale storia sentirò
cosa leggero o studierò per aprirmi la
testa
ciò che può ancora appassionarci in
qualsiasi condizione di salute
di vita o di lavoro è in prospettiva e
riguarda anche voi
non c'entra solo col tumore
avete provato a girare l'angolo e a
guardare la vostra vita da un altro
punto di vista
con immaginazione
con apertura agli altri col sorriso con
un po di ironia
con fiducia con amore
avete scelto la vostra casa
il vostro punto di ri partenza
quotidiano per riscriverla alla vostra
storia perché c'è un futuro ma noi
agiamo e diventa presenta
il to play in punto più
[Musica]
[Applauso]